Speaker 1: Welcome to the show, everybody. I said
yesterday, which was our first show of the year
and the first show of the week, that as soon as we
had kind of catch up data from the holiday weekend
about COVID, we would look at the numbers and that
it's expected that the numbers are off the wall.
Shocking, appalling numbers. And indeed they
are. When it comes to cases, the numbers are
appallingly bad when it comes to testing in
terms of the difficulty of getting a test and the
extremely high positivity rate of tests showing
how incredibly widespread this Micron variant is.
But we continue to see death numbers
that, while they are still tragic,
are making us hopeful that this cybercrime
variant is going to burn through the population
in maybe the next four to six weeks without a
proportionately high death toll. And then go,
now what happens after that? There are three
or four different perspectives which we will
eventually talk about, but let's take a look at
the numbers and they are just incredible. How
contagious this thing is, is really, really
hard to believe in the United States now
just a vertical increase. And we'll look at the
exact numbers. If you look at the day by day
days of nearly six consecutive days of
nearly 600000 cases in a single day,
and a lot of the backlog data is still being
cataloged. But these are incredible numbers
at this point. If we have 500000
cases a day that we know about,
we would expect that the real number of infections
is between one million and 1.5 million actual
infections a day to account for home tests
that don't show up in these data and to account
for people who never get tested. 20 percent
positivity rates in many states and big cities.
If we look over at this is this is death, let's
not go there yet. If we look at global cases,
we see that global cases are now reaching
two million cases a day that we know about
that we know about and with the difficulty of tax
testing that also exists in many other countries.
Some countries have great testing. Some countries
don't. We can also safely estimate the real number
of infections if officially it's two million
cases a day, there's probably between four and six
million infections per day or even more.
If you think about just the U.S. numbers,
actually. But before we get to that article
from CNBC, U.S. reports over one million new
daily COVID cases. The U.S. has reported a record
single day number of COVID cases, with more than a
million new infections. A total of 1.2 million
new cases were reported Monday yesterday, per
Johns Hopkins University, as the highly infectious
al-Muqrin variant continues to spread throughout
the country and beyond. The U.S. also has the
highest seven day average of new daily cases
in any country tracked by Johns Hopkins. This
brings the total confirmed cases to 56 million.
Over 800 and 27000 deaths. Now, the record single
day total may be due in part to delayed reporting
from the holiday weekend. So that's what's really
important to look at when you might be saying
David. Wait. So if if a million were reported
yesterday, why does Worldometer say that it was
only four hundred and six 26000 a million were
reported yesterday. Some were from January 3rd,
some were from January 2nd, some were from January
1st and December 31st. So we're rapidly getting up
there for a moment. Let's imagine that the real
number of cases just to make the math easy is 1.6
million a day. Why do I pick 1.6 million? Well,
the U.S. has a population of about 330 million,
so 1.6 million, 1.6 five million would
be exactly half of one percent per day.
If you start doing the math and you think
about, well, some people, if you have three
shots of Moderna or Pfizer, you're about 75
percent protected from symptomatic infection. So
when we think about the population, if there's
some people who have recovered from prior COVID
and have protection, some protection from Akron,
it's diminished, but some protection from it. Ron,
you have some people then who even
if exposed, aren't going to get it.
You then have people who have three shots, which
gives you some significant protection against
Macron. Although vaccinated people are getting
this all over the place, we know that. So you've
got that population. And then if every two days
one percent of the population is getting it, you
start doing the math. 30 days of this high case
rate is going to have most of the country exposed.
Many will get it. Many will be asymptomatic.
Some will be exposed and fight it off thanks
to vaccination or prior immunity in 30 days.
There can only be one path for Macron, and
it's down very quickly, and we're seeing that in
South Africa now, could there be another variant?
Of course. Could there be all sorts of different
things, of course. But when you have something
this contagious where every two days one percent
of your population is getting it in a country this
big and you have some immunity in the population
and you have some vaccine production in the
population, at some point something has to break.
And so the cautious optimism is that this will get
us much closer to the end of the pandemic phase.
What about deaths? The good news continues to be.
That deaths are not spiking, the emissions spike
in cases started right around Thanksgiving.
And while there has been an increase in
deaths, the average daily going from about
900 up to about 12500. Cases are dramatically
higher and the deaths are not yet spiking,
and it's been a while we're into five weeks now in
South Africa are Micron led to a case increase of
one hundred and fifty x a day. One hundred and
fifty times increase in cases and deaths only
doubled. Now, South Africa is different in a lot
of ways much younger population than the U.S.,
as I said yesterday, et cetera, et cetera. But
the fact that deaths are not spiking in proportion
with cases is very good. Globally, deaths continue
to decline at the start of the the AMA run
spread. Global deaths were at about 7000 a day,
and now global deaths are under 6000 a day.
We're cautious, we're cautious, but this is
reason to be cautiously optimistic. One last thing
on this? The CDC has shortened the waiting period
for Pfizer COVID boosters to five month. Remember,
the CDC had said get your third dose at least
six months after your second dose. Now the CDC
is saying five months, and it is believed that
part of the reason is that that third dose is so
much more effective at preventing symptomatic
illness from Akron that the recommendation is
changing. So that is a very good thing. These
are the numbers as we have them right now.
We're going to continue to follow them. It's
both appalling the difficulty of getting tests.
And the number of cases, it also is a sign to say,
wow, if cases are this high and we're not seeing
deaths spike dramatically, that's a really,
really good sign. We will follow the science.